Silicon Valley
Bank's failure is having a real impact.
Do you need proof of that?
Look at the toy store camp.
There are venture backed retailers.
And on Friday,
they sent an email out to their customers
to put up this ad,
put it up right there
on their website, it said.
When you bank
when your bank
collapse, run, don't walk right to say
40% at camp,
the caption say,
I never liked the Bay Area.
And could this happen?
How could this happen?
This all sucks.
Promo code bank run.
Is all right.
So, Poppy, we're
you know, we're talking about kids
toys here.
And you're live at the camp store
right now.
Poppy, what are you seeing?
Hello.
Hey, guys.
Good morning.
We're with Ben
Kaufman, the founder of Camp and the CEO.
This is your idea over the weekend.
And we're smiling
because thank goodness
your deposits are now assured
because of the federal government.
But this was
a last ditch effort over the weekend
to try not to collapse.
That's how dependent you guys were
on SDB.
Yeah.
About 85% of our company's
cash assets were at 85%.
Millions of dollars in stock.
Okay.
So what happened to you Friday?
So on Friday,
when we got the alert
that the FDIC was
was taking control of the bank,
we had no idea
what would be the next step.
We did not know
how long it was going to take
for us to get our cash out.
We still kind of don't they say
today, we'll see. We'll see what happens.
You don't know if you can get your money.
What we hope we hope we can.
And we're so grateful
that the Fed stepped
in in the way they did.
But we
did what startups do, which is we
we kind of took matters into our own hand
and we kind of had that fight
for survival.
It's a similar fight for survival.
We felt
when when COVID happened
and we ran an experiment through a store.
And so we turn to our most loyal group
of customers and said, hey, we need
we need inflows of cash right now.
We set up a new account
and kind of pushed our weekend sales
to a new account.
JP Morgan Chase. JP Morgan Chase.
And we said we need your help.
And the outpouring of support
was so absolutely critical
to all our viewers.
And guys back in the studio.
The reason that I wanted to have been on
is I'm one of those loyal customers.
I got little kids.
You've got three little kids.
I get this email Saturday,
Friday afternoon, and I'm like,
wow, they are turning to
everyone who's a customer
to try to save the business.
That's how dire the streets were for you.
Yeah, we had to pretend
like it was the end of times.
And not pretended it felt that way. Yes.
And we had to find a way to
to fight for survival.
And that was, again,
turning to customers,
providing them
with a little bit of offer. Right.
There was
there was value in it for customers.
We offered 40% off, and we were
we were so lucky to have so much
amazing support
in all the things
that keep you up at night.
As the founder of a business,
small business of as a startup.
Did you ever think that your deposits
that were largely held in, you know,
securities, treasuries, bonds,
would not be available?
No.
I mean, like you
said, like running a startup as hard,
running a retailer as hard
running a DTC product.
Companies are running out of running
an experiential environment. It's hard.
We never had to think about
like the safety of our bank.
That's an added layer. Okay.
So I spoke to a lot of founders
this weekend and
another startup founder
and CEO told me that it was a requirement
that if you got lending from SVP,
you had to hold all of your cash
deposit there.
They required that. Is that true for you?
It was true.
At a certain point
in our company's history,
we had a line of credit with SDB.
We no longer did at the time.
Of the collapse.
But because all of you know,
when you check out of the register,
the money automatically went to CB.
It was all kind of wired in.
Yeah, just we
we never actually transferred that away.
Once that but that it would explain why
so many founders and startups had all of
their cash in this bank. Yes.
Yeah.
We there was it was bank to use.
And they made you do that
if you wanted to get credit from them.
Yep. What do you do?
Have a message for the management group
or the CEO? The management of SVP.
Do you think this is bad management?
I don't know.
I mean, I'm I'm I'm not a toy store.
Yes. I'm not an economist.
I don't know how to manage,
you know, money at that scale.
I, frankly, like SVP, was there for us
when we needed them.
They were there for other startups,
so we needed them.
And again, startups are hard.
And is that why
you didn't pull all your money out
when you heard all this Twitter chatter
and VC talking about pulling money out?
We attempted to on Thursday.
And you think it just didn't settle
at the other bank.
I have to think of all your employees
first. What?
So what were they saying to you?
What were they feeling?
Well, again,
we were lucky to have an account
already set up at JPMorgan Chase.
I the first thing I said to our employees
is that we have
a little bit of cash there
because if you pay in cash in our stores,
you know, the store managers
ran it over to Chase.
We had a little bit of cash
and we knew we were going to be able
to make payroll this week.
But we said, like,
the future is uncertain,
we don't know what the next step
is going to be.
And so we again,
we turned to the turn to customers
and immediately store managers
as saying there was
the stores were packed.
And you know what
we saw
online from people
that were
not only existing customers,
but new customers wanting to support
this brand was,
you know, I'll never forget it.
It's amazing.
I'm so glad.
Does it change finally how you
hold your money going forward?
Do you now split it up?
I think a lot of heads of small companies
and startups are thinking,
do we put 20% in this bank
and 20% this bank and 20% in this bank.
Yeah,
I think that's going
to have to be a consideration
moving forward.
You know, I don't want to do this again.
No, no one.
We're glad you're okay.
You're going to make your next payroll.
We sure are.
I mean, again, like we
the support this weekend was incredible.
We're just going to go back
to the regular startup fights,
you know, the regular,
you know, fighting, fighting for survival
that every startups do,
even when they're banking stable.
You made it through COVID,
you made it through this
I told you we'd get all of our kids.
Thank you.
Christmas gifts, birthday gifts.
You know, the staff is always so lovely.
Good luck. Thank you so much.
Very much. Extra.
Ben Kaufman. Hey, guys, back to you.
And one of the coolest
old school rocking horses
in that store,
Poppy, as you know,
they love the old school.
It's one of my favorites.
It was great. I love that.
He said I'm a toy store owner.
Right.
Not an economist and an economist.
And I think that speaks
to a lot of folks,
what a lot of folks are dealing with.